WASHINGTON, D.C., WHEN YOU
COMMIT CANDOR, WHICH IS WHAT I
DID.
>> Neil: REPRESENTATIVE MIGHT
CALL IT CANDOR, BUT HIS ACTIONS
LAST TIME ALMOST STOPPING OR
CERTAINLY DELAYING THE LAST
STIMULUS PACKAGE DIDN’T WIN HIM
SUPPORT AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WAS
GRANDSTANDING.
BOTH ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
HAD LAST YEAR THINGS TO SAY.
THIS IS SPINNING ON TOP OF MORE
SPENDING.
IN ADDITION TO THIS SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN COMMITMENT.
IT’S REALLY A PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
LINDSEY GRAHAM JOINS ME IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
HE’S SAYING, ENOUGH ALREADY,
COOL IT.
SPEAK TO WHO?
IS THAT YOUR QUESTION?
WHAT DO I THINK OF HIM?
>> Neil: YES.
>> THAT’S YOUR QUESTION?
>> Neil: HE DOESN’T WANT ANY
MORE MONEY BEING SPENT.
HE SAYS ENOUGH.
>> HE NEVER WANTS TO GIVE A DIME
TO ISRAEL.
WE GET SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT HIM, BUT I WOULD
RATHER NOT.
LET ME TELL YOU WHY I THINK THIS
IS A GOOD PROGRAM.
IT’S GOT A MAJOR PROBLEM.
BACK HERE AT HOME I’VE HEARD A
LOT OF CRITICISM AND CONCERN
ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
THE GOAL IS TO KEEP THE EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP INTACT.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO, YOU GO TO A
BANK IF YOU CAN FIND ONE.
YOU BORROW UP TO 2.5 TIMES YOUR
PAYROLL, WHAT EXISTED
FEBRUARY 15TH.
YOU PAY YOUR EMPLOYEES 75% OF
THE MONEY.
THAT KEEPS THE COMPANY INTACT,
SO WHEN THE ECONOMY OPENS UP,
YOU’RE GOOD TO GO.
COUNT ME IN FOR THAT.
HERE’S WHAT’S NOT WORKING.
THE BANKS ARE HARD TO ACCESS IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A PRE-EXISTING
RELATIONSHIP.
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH BANKS.
THE BIG PROBLEM WITH THIS
PROGRAM IS THE UNEMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM IS COMPETING WITH A LOAN
PROGRAM.
HIS WET HAPPENS.
YOU PAY EMPLOYEES $17 AN HOUR,
WELL, HERE’S YOUR DILEMMA.
YOU ARE PAYING THEM $17 AN HOUR
TO STAY ON YOUR PAYROLL.
SOUTH CAROLINA UNEMPLOYMENT
SYSTEM SPENDING $23 TO LEAVE
YOUR PAYROLL.
SO, WE’VE GOT VERY GENEROUS
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THAT
EXCEED PEOPLE’S WAGES.
IT’S HARD FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
TO GET THEIR EMPLOYEES ON THE
PAYROLL, BECAUSE THE STATE OF
SOUTH CAROLINA IS OFFERING THEM
$23 NOT TO BE ON YOUR PAYROLL.
IF WE DON’T FIX THAT, WE ARE
NEVER GOING TO GET THIS RIGHT.
>> Neil: WHEN YOU QUOTE
STIMULUS AND GENEROUS MEASURES,
GOVERNOR CUOMO IN NEW YORK WANTS
TO ADD TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
CHECKS PEOPLE ARE GETTING IN
NEW YORK BY ANOTHER $600 ON TOP
OF THE $600 THAT THEY ARE
GETTING THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
HE SAYS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL REIMBURSE HIM.
DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> HERE’S WHAT I THINK.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
ENTREPRENEURIAL NATION.
PEOPLE LIKE THEIR WORK, BUT THEY
ARE GOING TO MAKE THE DECISION
BEST FOR THEIR FAMILY.
MY GOAL IS, IF YOU GET LAID OFF
AND K GO TO WORK, NO FAULT OF
YOUR OWN AND NOBODY WILL OFFER
YOU A JOB, THAT WE MAKE YOU
HOLE.
IF YOU ARE MAKING $15 AN HOUR,
THAT $1600 A WEEK, I WANT YOU TO
BE MADE HOLE.
THE MAXIMUM UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT
PER WEEK IN SOUTH CAROLINA AT
$326.
I’M WILLING TO MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE.
BUT WE HAVE DONE IS ADDED $600
ON TOP OF $326.
SO NOW, YOU’RE MAKING $23 AN
HOUR.
AT THE PROBLEM IS, IF YOU ARE
WALMART AND AMAZON -- NEIL, YOU
KNOW THIS BETTER THAN 91.
THE STATE OF SOUTH CAROLINA --
TEXAS IS $28 AN HOUR.
WE’VE MADE IT HARD FOR PEOPLE TO
FIND NEW WORKERS, BECAUSE YOU
ARE PAYING PEOPLE MORE NOT TO
WORK.
I AM FOR MAKING PEOPLE HOLD, BUT
I’M NOT FOR PAYING THEM OR NOT
TO WORK THAN THEY WERE MAKING AT
THEIR JOB.
>> Neil: FILE I HAVE YOU,
SENATOR, THERE’S BIG --
BETWEEN THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AND THE PRESIDENT.
I’M WONDERING WHETHER AS HE HAS
TALKED ABOUT MAYBE TAKING
FUNDING AWAY FROM THEM, BECAUSE
THEY WERE HIDING FIGURES ON
CHINA.
THAT IS THE ALLEGATION.
THE SEVERITY OF THE GROWTH OF
THE VIRUS IN CHINA.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> WELCOME AT THE CONGRESS
APPROPRIATES MONEY.
WE HAVE MONEY -- WE NEED AN
EFFECTIVE W.H.O.
I’M NOT GOING TO FUND A W.H.O.
ANY LONGER AS LONG AS THE
CURRENT DIRECTOR IS IN PLACE.
HE MUST RESIGN.
I’M GOING TO BE DR. NO WHEN IT
COMES TO FINDING THE W.H.O.
IT IS THE ACCOUNT THAT I’M IN
CHARGE OF.
I SIGNED A LETTER TODAY WAS 60
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, REPUBLICAN
OR DEMOCRAT’S COMPLAINING ABOUT
THE W.H.O.
THEY SAID ON JANUARY THE 10TH,
IT’S OKAY TO TRAVEL TO CHINA
WHEN THEY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
BETTER.
ON JANUARY THE 14TH, THEY SAID
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF HUMAN
TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS WITHIN
CHINA.
THEY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN BETTER.
IN 2015, THEY COMPLETELY BOTCHED
THE EBOLA VIRUS PROBLEM IN WEST
AFRICA.
THE CURRENT REGIME IS NOT A GOOD
INVESTMENT.
NO MORE MONEY FOR THE W.H.O.
UNTIL THEY GET NEW LEADERSHIP
AND REFORM THE WAY THEY DO
BUSINESS.
>> Neil: ALL RIGHT, SENATOR.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THEY SAY AND
DO, BECAUSE THEY ARE FIGHTING